get excited dudes the bill & ted's
through equal is coming and we have new
details straight from Keanu Reeves
himself so here we are today on the et
news i'ma be to be a villain 10th equal
news update back in 1989 we got this gem
of a movie what number we thinking of 69
and in 1991 the sequel excuse us
dude but your shoes are untied 25 years
later were inching closer to yet another
Bill and Ted films excellent here's what
Keanu Reeves told me on Wednesday while
promoting his new thriller the neon
demon we have a new draft of the script
that just came in I have to read um and
yeah we're still dealing with dough and
story but we're closer we're getting
closer I'm getting closer there been
movement there's been movement okay so
it is June 2016 June 2016
can I hope to get you into production by
the end of the year mmm I don't know
ambitious yeah that might be what can
fans expect is it what's the premise
it's funny it's about the pressure of
Bill and Ted having to have saved the
world and it not quite working out and
the toll it's taking on their families
Wow yeah they're breaking apart
suspense suspense oh my god then there's
something coming in them yeah they have
to save the world but they're not quite
succeeding and the families are breaking
apart Wow and how do they resolve this
well that's what that's the new boy
there's drama okay
are you and Alex winter clothes I think
vans have this idea that you guys like
hang out and grab drinks on the weekend
yeah we do um yeah he's one of my best
friends what is it about him and your
friendship that's lasted you know 12
years for me I mean his intelligence his
humor his hard yeah he's he's a cool cat
three words to describe the three Quall
bodacious ed excellent good um and a
hard morning I know funny guy said what
done we high-five to the threequel I'm
so excited about it